alright meanwhile as we pause to
remember our brave servicemen and women
who gave their lives fighting for our
freedom the Department of Veterans
Affairs is dealing with a tough issue
they're limiting access to VA cemeteries
and moving most Memorial Day ceremonies
online do of course - pandemic
restrictions one Florida congressman is
objecting Brian mast an army vet writing
this quote with many parts of our
country now in the process of a phased
reopening I find it appalling that
beaches will be open for the holiday but
that access to VA cemeteries will remain
restricted so the Secretary of Veterans
Affairs Robert Wilkie is joining us live
now good morning sir good morning thank
you for having me we appreciate you
being I want to give you a chance to
respond to that we'll go back and forth
on what's happening at VA cemeteries but
I would be remiss to not start by at
least giving you a chance to talk about
what it's like to serve this great
nation as VA secretary as the president
leads the nation in marking this
Memorial Day sir well as some of you
know I'm the son of a grievously wounded
combat soldier I still serve in the Air
Force Reserve my earliest memories that
are in elementary in kindergarten and
I've often said that when a classmate
was called to the principal's office
during those times in my youth there was
always a chance that that child wasn't
going to a doctor's appointment that
there was bad news from Southeast Asia
so I was able to see this through the
eyes of a child not only if my father's
recovery but the loss of so many of his
comrades particularly at Fort Bragg the
home of Special Forces and of course the
home of the 82nd Airborne Division the
one thing I always talk about and I said
this today at Quantico National Cemetery
the one thing that separates the
American warrior from all other fighting
forces in the history of the world is
that we are the only people to offer a
helping hand to all the peoples of the
world including our enemies and as
general Powell said so eloquently the
only thing we ever asked is a place to
bury our dead and I think that's a
fitting memorial to all of the over 1
million Americans who have perished
since the first shots were fired in
Lexington and a
of 1775 absolutely very well said but as
we talked about those who are married
it's a difficult subject obviously in
the middle of this pandemic about what
to do to give people a chance to honor
the dead so we mentioned congressman
mast he's a warrior himself as you know
he was grievously wounded as well a
veteran and his point is in part of the
letter that Americans should quote have
the freedom to mourn and pay their
respects in the manner they judge is
best for themselves and their groups so
talk about why you decided look we've
got to close off the VA cemeteries what
other ways you're offering for people to
mourn and when do you think they may
open sir well let me let me do something
hard up to correct the congressman
we have 142 VA cemeteries not one of
them has ever closed during this
epidemic I just spoke at the Quantico
National Cemetery and as I was speaking
I was looking out at families collecting
to memorialize their loved ones that's
happening all across the country what we
had stopped
we're gatherings of large groups like
the Boy Scouts in fact I issued a joint
statement earlier last week with the Boy
Scout leadership because thousands and
thousands of Boy Scouts would have been
in our cemeteries planting flags
well the Scout leadership decided in in
the terms of safety for them that they
would honor veterans through a virtual
celebration in it today
three o'clock all across the country
Scouts will participate in our veterans
Legacy Project and they will be standing
at attention as the bugler blows taps
and salute I would also note that in
Sandra's lead-in to the ceremony in
Arlington she noted that the Arlington
National Cemetery which is run by the
Department of the army where the
president was today the families were
there the families were there doing what
is most important and that is
memorializing and remembering their
loved ones and I think of all the things
that we do that is the most important
that is the most important element of
what we give to the nation at VA and
they they were able to perform those
sacred
mr. secretary in the last moment we have
closed might not have been the right
word restricted the congressman is
saying how do you how do you justify
that though that families have
restricted access to these VA cemeteries
well the families have access that's the
key and they've also had access when
we've had our burials and those burials
have been going on all across the
country but I would also note as was
hinted in your lead-in to the Arlington
piece we haven't had the benefit of
Department of Defense honor guards those
have been stopped for safety reasons
we'll return our cemeteries to full use
very shortly and and it is a tragedy in
one sense that we haven't been allowed
to bring masses of the American people
into our cemeteries but as long as the
families are allowed to go that's the
most important part of what we do it
certainly is and your words at the
beginning about your own family and you
as a young boy dealing with it and and
and some kids being called to the
principal's office to find out that they
lost a mom or a dad or an uncle or an
aunt we certainly appreciate your
sacrifice this great nation your family
as well thank you mr. secretary thank
you